Yeah.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast,
Dan.
Yeah.
I'm just checking in on you.
Just checking in to see how your day's going.
Give you a quick,
some fucking half hour laughs,
you know,
keep me in your thoughts and in your prayers.
Okay?
You're in our thoughts and you're in our prayers.
Speaking of that,
Houston,
Texas.
All right,
I got a warning for everybody.
All right?
There's going to be all
bunch of people making money off that fucking devastation down there.
All right?
Be careful where you send your money and cause people are going to make videos.
They're going to have your bottom lip quiver and you're going to feel bad for
them.
And the family fucking dog just makes sure it's getting to those people.
New York Times put our list of shit.
That's legit.
All right.
Fucking sat down.
Somebody sent me something of this woman saying she was a single mom with two
kids,
right?
And uh,
I didn't know what to do.
It's like,
do I sent,
does this get to you?
Is there a bald hairy back guy on the other end of this?
So I'm sticking with the Red Cross.
You know,
as I was looking at all those,
I just kept hearing that song.
How do I know that y'all really drown in,
right?
How do I fucking know?
How do I know this is not a scam?
Because people are such pieces of Shit Uk,
they will actually like I want to fuck,
I swear to God they could literally take it when they find those fucking people,
they find those people.
They should,
they should take all the money back,
give it to the victims.
And when the neck hurt,
next hurricane comes,
you dropped those fuckers right in the middle of it,
right in the middle of it.
And then when they cry for help,
nobody sends him fucking help.
That's what they should do.
The kinds of pieces of the shit that would fucking take advantage of people
during a situation like that.
So,
um,
yeah,
I would donate to the Red Cross.
I'm not going to tell you whether I'm donating or how much of doting and cause
I'm sick of fucking people talking about that.
You know,
I donate it.
[inaudible] they can you can you,
can you not make it about yourself?
Fucking celebrities.
Gee,
what,
what would they be doing if they weren't making everything about themselves?
Somebody else's absolute fucking devastation becomes an opportunity for them to
show how fucking amazing they are.
Ah,
fucking horrific.
Anyways,
I shot nine holes of golf when I was back east.
It was baggy.
She leaves your new family.
[inaudible] and um,
you know,
I love going out and playing golf.
I let you go out there.
There's a foursome.
Everybody's talking,
Shit,
I'm smoking a cigar.
I'm having a good time.
I don't keep score.
I don't give a fuck.
I think I've got a 27 combined in the first two holes.
I was just,
you know,
yeah,
I go,
I do it like John Daly.
Like I don't fucking,
I don't sit there in line,
the Goddamn ball up going gonna waste everybody's fucking time.
I just walk up and hit it.
I take one practice swing,
that's it.
Then I hit the fucking thing.
All right.
I just fucking wind up and you know,
I hit it straight.
It just doesn't go for.
So,
uh,
those guys started giving me tips.
I started listening to them and they just kept picturing how the swing on TV,
keep that front arms straight,
you know,
keep your leg down,
that type of shit.
And I ended up doing all right.
You know,
I started breaking eight on holes.
I hate when they go,
you can't score more than an eight on a whole.
It's like,
Oh yeah,
watch me,
watch me.
I'll still be 200 yards from the hole taking fucking shot number nine.
All right,
that is it.
That is a fucking myth.
My friend,
he has to do with like handicaps or something.
It's just yet another way,
you know,
so there's no cheating or whatever.
It's the biggest fucking cheat and game.
I'm trying to think other than like,
you know,
business.
Um,
so anyways,
I got down to the last hole I got,
I got like a s a seven on the eighth hole was psyched that I broke aid and then
on the last hole was a par four and I shot a four Sanka 30 fucking fun.
Yeah,
was all right.
It's all right.
And once again I just,
and then the guy who I was playing with,
the oldest guy in our group was like looking like it was pushing 60 and he shot
party tea party for nine holes.
Once again,
proving it's not a,
it's not a sport,
it's a game.
It's a fucking game.
There's no way it's 60.
You know what I mean?
That's like the basketball equivalent is still being able to dunk when you're 60
you know,
and I don't mean cause you're seven feet tall.
I mean you're like fucking six three.
He used to throw it down a little bit back in the day and then you come back for
the old timers game and you still fucking dunking.
He is still dropping 30 and then you're doing it on people like 20 years younger
than you get the fuck outta here.
Um,
but I got to admit I really didn't join somebody finally explained that.
Why you tee the ball up high?
I would teed up high and then try to hit it flush with the club.
I didn't know you kind of swung underneath it.
That was a game changer and uh,
okay.
That was the,
I dunno my shit as I stink kitten off the ground on the fairway.
I'm not good at that shit.
But I feel like I could take a couple of lessons and uh,
I could go out there and not embarrass myself.
MMM.
I only lost,
I only lost one.
I think two balls in nine holes.
That's pretty good for someone that never fucking plays my pat and myself.
Am I making this about myself?
Am I pulling some fucking move here?
Do you know how much money I donated to that golf course when I saw all those
white men out there?
I knew I had to do something.
Um,
that's why I created the fun for cause named after me with my face on it because
I care.
All right,
why does this thing always do this to me?
And then I,
I typed in the wrong fucking password,
didn't I?
And Go fuck yourself.
God dammit.
All right.
So yeah,
so I,
you know,
something,
I actually enjoy golf.
I don't have the fucking time for it,
but I do enjoy it.
Um,
I also,
uh,
was fucking with my first drunk kid I ever had and it's amazing now that I
actually know what a tune up the drums,
I got the snare to sound great,
but my fucking bass drum,
I don't know what was going on with it.
There was like this vibration of something,
no idea what it was.
Maybe that,
you know,
it's one of those that's an old school.
Slingerland maybe I didn't have the,
uh,
you know,
he has the clause on it,
which sucks because if you're gonna do like a quarter turn,
those ones that are on the ground,
you can't fucking do it.
He just got to be a guy.
We're just going to leave those ones alum.
But um,
I got the toms in the snare to sound good.
The bass drums,
the last fucking thing that I need to learn how to tune up and then I have a
nice jump off and I think I'll actually Sunday actually be able to tune up a set
of drums.
Make them Sandra.
Right.
That's the goal anyways.
That is the goal,
you know,
shooting less than an eight when I go out and golf every seven years and uh,
being able to Napa fucking set of drums.
By the way,
speaking of that Queens of the stone age,
his new album,
have you listened to it yet?
Jesus Christ.
It's fucking amazing.
Listen to it twice.
I loved it the first time.
It was even better the second time.
And um,
okay.
He got out on.
No,
you don't have to check it out.
I'm just saying if you like fucking great music,
I would definitely check that out.
That's what I've been listening to it.
But listening to that and um,
what's his face there with the fuck is my phone.
I can't remember any,
anything anymore.
The fuck is the guy's name.
Okay.
The Guy who sings a Marlo Vizo Phi.
Yeah.
Uh,
uh,
the fuck is his name.
Okay.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
I gotta look up dream weaver.
Weaver.
No,
so we're not going to do,
we'll,
we'll drink Gary.
Right.
Gary writes album the fuck's the name of the album here.
It's called the dream.
We are no Nada.
Is that the,
what's it called,
the dream weaver?
It's under soft rock,
but we don't,
Andy Newmark,
one of my new favorite fucking drum is plays on it and he's unbelievable.
I just switched to drums are more up in the mix.
Something about like drums in the fucking seventies they just,
it was like they had a towel over the entire fucking kit.
They can't hear anything.
I'm,
once again,
the genius of John Bond them to be like,
dude,
fuck that.
You can't hear the drums.
I wish.
I wish they would remaster that fucking album and bring Andy's drums up so I can
hear him.
It's fucking incredible.
Incredible player and everybody sleeps on that album.
Everybody just downloads Dreamweaver and love is alive.
Can't find the judges.
Great.
Let it out is great blind feeling.
It's a fucking tremendous album.
And what he wanted to do evidently was good to get away from that.
You wanted to have like a fucking get away from everything being guitar based.
I don't think it's soft rock doe.
Some of it is,
but not all of it.
It's got some balls.
Right?
Does anybody know what I'm talking about or who I'm talking about?
Probably not.
Oh,
look who's in town this week.
The Boston Red Sox had going to the fucking New York Yankees.
I got two of my buddies.
I'm Ben,
50 bucks a game for the rest of the year.
I'm up,
I'm up 100 on both of them.
Uh,
am I?
Yeah,
I think I'm up 100 bucks on both of them.
So I'm up 200 bucks total.
So I went to lose a hundred depending on if the red sox win or lose.
So worst case scenario,
I'm down 200 bucks this weekend,
I believe.
I think that's what it is,
right?
Yeah.
That's what the fuck it is.
Um,
I'm hoping we've been playing great.
They got swept,
but they played the fucking Indians.
The Indians are on fire.
So we'll see what happens with backup to a five and a half game lead.
I'm loving that.
And who knows?
With any luck,
we'll play the Yankees and the,
and the fucking playoffs hasn't happened in a long time since 2004.
If I was a giants fan,
I would bring that up all the time.
Um,
I remember when new champion 15 years ago,
we've won championships since then.
Everybody,
it doesn't matter.
You can do it that year.
Um,
like Yankee Fan.
So you give a shit about 2004 considering you one in 2009,
does it really hurt?
You know what I mean?
Exactly.
All right.
So,
um,
all Billy,
no fun.
14 fucking days,
no booze.
Once I get this far out in front of it,
once they get this far out in front of it,
I could literally go a year,
um,
you know,
I could go the rest of my fucking life.
I just don't choose to,
you know,
it's fun.
I enjoy it,
but fortunately I don't have that fucking chemical think.
Did I already talk about this because I've started this podcast like 19 times
because I'm never funny generally.
And I'm really not funny on days when I fucking fly.
Um,
so I'm 14 days in.
I did real good with the,
when I was back east for the first couple of days in the last two days I fucked
up,
uh,
in a major way.
Lots of pizzas and that type of shit.
Um,
I went to my favorite pizza spot twice and then,
uh,
I got this other new spot where I got ahead of free some fucking pizzas for me
and I'm trying to send them out here through dry ice and all that bullshit.
We'll see what the fuck happens.
Um,
we'll see if it happens,
man.
Um,
should I read some at this point?
Is that what I should do?
I think I've talked about everything that I promote the surf ballroom in clear
Lake Iowa,
by the way,
it November 5th,
I think is what I'm going to be there.
That's where buddy Holly,
the big Bopper in Ritchie Valens last play it and be there with Dean del Ray.
And I know I brought this up on Monday,
but I got to keep promoting this fucking date because they don't do a lot of
standup dates.
I'm performing there because I'm a fan of music and,
uh,
I always wanted to see that it's like a museum slash place where you can
perform.
So I was like,
why don't I just fucking do both and make a little bit of money?
I get to see this.
They get to pay my respects.
You know what I mean?
But I will tell you what,
I am not going to be playing any of that fucking music that night cause I'm sure
everybody who works there is so God damn sick of hearing a pig.
He says,
you pay gets to you pick the pig seat.
I'm not going to do the to,
um,
I'm going to do the,
uh,
the movie version of it to Gary Busey version of it.
You know,
just to switch things up for you.
All right,
what am I doing here?
Let's,
uh,
by the way,
it's about people given Donald Trump shit.
Whenever there's a fucking natural disaster,
they always give the standing president shit like,
like what is he fucking Zeus as he supposed to stop it from happening?
You know,
I heard something today that one of the problems was,
it was one,
the people that developed in Houston,
they paved over a bunch of wetlands that would have absorbed a lot of that
water,
which then got them talking about how out here in La that they've,
they've built over land that was just,
it's just going to disintegrate,
you know,
whenever we have a big earthquake or something.
Um,
cause they were like,
well why don't we do about out here now that we sell what's going on in Houston,
what should we do out here?
I'm like,
there's no fucking hurricanes out here.
But there's always something.
The old earthquakes already,
Aaron,
when Aaron,
he comes to town,
um,
shaking everything up,
right?
It's like your absentee father comes off the road after a fucking three year
bender starts telling you to make your bed,
you know,
like are you fucking doing that?
Then he beats you like he doesn't even know you.
That's what an earthquake is like.
Um,
all right,
let's read some advertising here.
Okay.
What do we got here?
Oh,
Jesus.
These people are new.
Sue,
do you play sports or workout a lot?
Talk about how sore you can get from that and now I can trigger injuries.
Why?
Why isn't this shit ever edited out of the fucking reading?
Oh,
I played golf this weekend.
It's now this week.
It's not really a sport.
It's an activity.
I felt fine after.
It's certainly after I s fucking sank that 30 foot.
Uh,
I do work out.
I fucked up my,
uh,
my shoulder,
you know?
Yeah.
It's annoying that I talk about it long enough.
All right.
Lead into your personal endorsement.
Talk about your personal experience with your soothing massage.
I don't even know what it is.
I haven't.
How relaxed you are afterwards,
how easy it was to book,
how excited you are for the next booking,
et cetera.
All right.
Now,
now that after they wrote me all that,
I guess I'm supposed to look at this shit before do this sue.
There's an on demand massage service.
Wow.
Geez.
Oh Geez.
Is now.
Okay.
Do you get to see what you must Seuss looks like he is swiping left.
What's going on here?
Ah,
sue,
there's an on demand massage service that delivers a hand selected,
licensed and experienced massage therapist to you in the comfort of your own
home hotel or office in his little as an hour.
Sue's shows up.
I'm sure these people are above board,
but you know,
there's always a couple of dirty cops out there that'll take bribe money.
So there's an odd man I read that.
Um,
sue the shows up with everything.
They bring the massage table,
the sheets,
the oil and even music to drown you out at the end.
Ah,
so you can unwind no matter where you are.
I'm sorry,
I'm being really immature,
really mature.
This is all above board.
There's no fucking way we would,
we would do something like that.
You choose the kind of massage you want from Swedish and sport,
the deep tissue and more that just fucking Laba in this opening and that you can
even opt for couples massages.
All right,
here we go.
Get a little fucking freaky set.
The length of your massage and uh,
get to also pick the gender of your therapist aren't right for the homophobes
out there.
Therapists can earn over three and a half times what they make it a spa while
maintaining incredibly an incredible schedule flexibility.
That means you can even book a massage for 10:00 PM on a Wednesday.
This also brings the best therapist to the PSU.
That network you can book via the iPhone or Android App on the web.
Sooth is in 50 cities including most major US cities and London,
Sydney,
Melbourne,
Toronto and Vancouver.
A book a massage.
As soon as today,
our listeners are getting a special offer that will get you a $20 off your first
massage when you use our code bird download sooth,
s o,
t,
h,
e or so,
the um,
in the ios app store or Google play store.
And be sure to use our code bird to get $20 off your first massage.
Soothe Spock quality massage anytime,
anywhere.
You know,
if they can legalize weed,
why can't they just legalize a hand job at the end of a fucking massage?
You know what I mean?
Jesus Christ.
And just so like the women wouldn't get all fucking upset cause God,
they should have some for women too.
But I'm just saying I go,
oh my God.
But it starts with dad and any wide yet touching her,
just have him strap you down like a fucking love bottomy patient and you know,
and then that's it.
Then you can't touch him by he do you know how much mapo peaceful the fucking
world would be if every guy started the day with the massage and a fucking hand
job.
Do you know,
achieve more.
We would listen to you.
I mean,
and I don't mean to be a fucking asshole here,
but ladies,
we've been asking you to do this for us for years.
And evidently,
you know,
after two,
three months into the relationship,
it's outs.
It's,
it's not your pay grade anymore.
Yeah.
Okay.
And what's funny is you could,
you could see,
you fucking ladies are going to come at me like I'm a fucking animal.
Despite the fact,
you know,
this is how guys are wired and you use it to your advantage.
Whenever you want to fucking rounded drench,
you fucking let the girls out a little bit,
right?
You look at somebody just long enough for them to fucking throw down their card.
You get your drink and then you go,
oh,
excuse me that I have a very important call over this way with at the table just
opened up.
Um,
yeah,
and if elected pan jobs at the end of massages would be made legal,
provided the male was strapped down by the wrist,
um,
then you get out of like an express massage window when you don't have time for
the full body massage and you just pull up like those drive through Starbucks
with like your deck out in some,
some chick just reaches out and fucking rubs went out.
There you go.
Then you fucking drive to work,
you know,
cause she's stopping at the yellow light at that point.
What the fuck do you care?
You know,
I hope women don't get offended by this.
Well,
who's getting,
no,
I don't give a shit.
If you're doing it,
but you know,
rather than look down at med,
why don't you understand,
you know,
and try to have empathy and understand what it is that we're going through.
Oh my God,
that would be fucking tremendous.
Drive through fucking massage.
You know what I mean?
And it's,
you know,
this is what would shut it down.
Some dope would also try to add a coffee machine to it and eventually someone
would spill coffee on the deck and that would be just a fucking lawsuit.
They would take the whole industry down.
All right.
I don't know.
I'm just brainstorming here.
Alright.
Oh Dodo.
Dope.
Dope me undies.
Mia.
Andy is,
why can't you rob won out booboo due to Biondi beyond these.
I'll keep quiet.
I won't shout.
If we could be legal,
why not be a job?
And when you come in,
you're fucking Soffe shorts.
Oh Jesus.
It went off the rails.
Ah,
you want to look good in your underwear and be comfortable,
right.
We'll throw you a,
but that perfect balance is hard to find.
Yeah.
Especially if you're a fat fuck like me.
You know what I mean?
Let's not blame the underwear here.
That's not blame the victim that's holding up the weight of my fucking mistakes.
Don't sacrifice style or comfort.
Checkout me undies,
man.com
and find the best pair of underwear in the world.
Me undies will be the most comfortable pair of underwear you will own made from
a sustainably sourced naturally soft fabric that is three times softer than
cotton for the hi me undies,
diamonds seem pouch.
Tommy on these,
I swear to God.
Diamond,
same pouch.
Laka
cradles your jewels and gives you stuff to support it needs without feeling too
light.
Are there any male Kardashians?
I bet they'd like something like that.
You know like it's like a bit dazzled fucking cell phone cover for your junk.
Ladies will love this.
Soft ecofriendly fabrics so soft and touchable.
What?
Gross 100% satisfaction guaranteed.
They guaranteed you will it guarantee you will love your undies.
Fuck did this Gringo or you'll get your money back right now me and he's having
an exclusive on it for,
for just my listeners.
Get 20% off your first pair and free shipping and the undies is so sure you will
love you their underwear.
They even offer a hundred percent satisfaction guaranteed.
You can order a pair and if you don't love your first pair of get a full refund,
this is a no brainer.
It's a no brainer to try.
It's 20% off free shipping,
a hundred percent satisfaction guarantee.
The fuck are you waiting for to get you 20% off free shipping and there are a
hundred percent satisfaction guarantee and the best Goddamn fucking softest
underwear you'll ever where we go to [inaudible] dot com slash bird this is a
limited time offer.
Really.
It's an air all your copy.
So what are you waiting for?
Start wearing the best underwear of your life.
It changed my life.
Did it?
It's time to let me undies change yours.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash burr right now.
All right,
two more.
Two more.
Hang in there.
Frame bridge,
everybody.
Do you ever take a dick pic and you just lose it and your phone?
Wouldn't it be great if you could just send it out to get framed and he could
look up at it every morning and smile.
Frame Bridge is the easiest way to custom frame your favorite art and photos
without ever leaving your house with their simple online ordering process.
You can order a fully customized piece and minutes.
Here's how it works.
Go to frame bridge.com I did this with my favorite picture of me and my daughter
and I have it right on my desk and I love it.
Upload your photo from your computer or directly from your Instagram feed.
Or if you have a physical,
physical item,
uh,
they'll provide secure prepaid packaging so you can mail it in for free.
Preview your photo online in any frame style.
Choose your favorite or get free help from their talented designers,
the expert team at frame bridge.
We'll custom frame your item in days,
not weeks or months and deliver your finished piece directly to your door.
Ready to hang.
This is perfect one.
There's a birthday coming up,
a little collage action right?
There you go.
Uh,
the best part.
Where would anything we better if sooth was actually given out hand jobs.
I'm asking you plus my listeners,
oh,
sorry about that,
and the best part,
instead of hundreds of dollars,
you'd pay it for the framing store.
Their prices start at just 39 bucks and all shipping is free.
Plus don't think just rolling into the 39 bucks.
Plus my listeners will get 15% off their first order@framebridge.com when they
use my code.
Burr frame bridge even offers a happiness guarantee.
If for any reason you aren't 100% satisfied with your order,
Brad,
they'll make it right.
Give your personal experience using frame bridge.com I just did the site,
the ease.
That was easy.
It was great,
and now I look at that picture of my daughter and I makes it makes me almost
tear up.
It's so beautiful.
Go to frame bridge.com and use Promo Code burpee you are and you'll save an
additional 15% off your first order.
Just go to [inaudible] dot com promo code,
[inaudible] dot Com Promo Code Burr.
You know what sucks is as a heat wave out here and I always take my daughter for
walks at night or during the dusk or whatever the fuck you want to call it.
That's our little,
uh,
you know,
daddy daughter thing that we do.
It's awesome.
She loves it.
The wind starts coming in off of the ocean,
you know,
blowing on a little tootsies she loves it.
Uh,
all right,
lift.
If you're choosing a ride sharing company to drive for,
go with the company that treats you better than the one that rhymes with mover.
It's Lyft.
Lyft was the first to offer in APP tipping.
When you drive for lit man,
you get to keep 100% of the tips.
Drivers of pay had been paid over 200 million in tips since the feature was
introduced.
Express pay lets drivers get paid almost instantly instead of waiting for weeks
lift as even taking the guesswork out of pickups.
Where is he?
The new APP device uses color coding to help passages find their drivers.
You can earn hundreds of dollars a week plus tips.
You want to earn more money,
drive more,
drive more.
It's never been easier to give yourself a race.
It's a simple formula.
Happy drivers being happy passengers.
Maybe that's why nine out of 10 Lyft rides get a perfect five star rating.
Go to lift.com/bar today and you can get a $500 new driver bonus.
That's lyft.com/burr lyft.com/burr limited time only terms do apply.
All right.
I'm laying on the floor and my fucking back trying to fix that fucking crib
downstairs.
Ugh.
That's the thing.
Once your kid just gets over like fucking seven,
eight months,
you know,
it's just like you pick it up,
this sack of potatoes,
you don't,
you didn't have a squat down to do it right.
You bend at the waist,
right?
Blowing out your lower back.
It's the fucking worst.
Um,
all right.
What the hell did I want to talk about?
Was there anything to talk about beyond,
yeah,
what everybody else is talking about.
I tried to stay outside of all of that.
You know what I mean?
Everybody's like,
you know,
talking about it,
raining down in Houston,
right?
The hurricane and all of that shit.
Am I going to be yet another?
I guess I already did,
but I did it in a way.
I actually told you to watch out for these fucking scams.
How do I know?
Right?
You always got to ask that because I gave a bunch of money to that wounded
warriors thing and then I got all this information that it was a fucking scam.
I don't know if it is or not,
but there was enough fucking article that it was,
and it made me nervous that allegedly that's what they were doing over there and
they fucking turned me off to charities that,
that they could possibly be somebody out there then,
you know,
watching that pink lady in the NFL.
So make sure you fucking money,
you know,
gets to the people.
Speaking of which Ron White is doing a gig out in Austin,
Texas,
he's going out with some other comedians in all,
all the proceeds are going to be going to,
uh,
you know,
help out the people there in Houston.
Um,
so there's a good one you can go to.
All right.
I wasn't able to make the GIG and I said,
well who should I make the check out to?
He said,
Red Cross.
All right.
So then I looked it up.
Is the Red Cross?
I know,
I saw him on mash.
Are they reputable?
And they checked out.
They are reputable.
So there you go.
All right.
And with that,
I am completely out of shit to talk about.
I don't know what I've talked about cause I've started this fucking podcast 15
fucking times.
I have no goddamn idea.
You know,
so I don't know what to tell you people other than this is the end of this
podcast right here.
But even though it is the end,
I'm going to continue to talk for another fucking two minutes and three seconds.
Contractually obligated to do a half hour here.
All right,
there you go.
You want to hear a fucking first world problem?
I got bumped up to first class,
right?
And uh,
they sat me in the last row right by the bulkhead,
so my fucking seat didn't recline.
You know,
and that ladies and gentlemen is a classic example of cold lotion.
Remember called Lotion?
I'm bringing it back.
Cold Lotion.
Classic example of fucking Cold Lotion.
If you don't know what it means,
it's in the urban dictionary.
It's basically somebody gives you something nice,
but it fucking sucks.
It's like,
hey,
somebody says,
want to put?
Say,
you know,
your back's all dried out.
Your wife goes,
Hey,
can you put some lotion on your back?
You Go,
absolutely.
She goes,
thank you sweetie.
But you know,
warming up and your hands yet you just slap it right on her back.
She's like,
yeah,
right,
right there as some fucking cold lotion.
You get bumped up to first class.
You were in the last row.
You seats up against the bulkhead.
See,
you can't fucking lean back.
Cold fucking lotion.
But I'll tell you what I watch.
I watched three movies,
two and a half movies.
I watched,
um,
founder starring Michael Keaton about,
uh,
how the whole Mcdonald's franchise came about and it was fantastic movie.
Loved it.
Then I watched the original alien,
which totally holds up other than their computers cause what's fucking hilarious
as they're flying through space,
doing shit we still can't do today.
But like the computers,
you know,
it looks like from fucking war games.
I don't know.
It's 1979 technology.
MMM.
But everything about what movie was fucking awesome and said go any waiver was
fucking bad ass and everybody should have listened to her.
That fucking,
I can't say what happens.
You know,
they didn't listen to her.
Um,
she felt she wanted to follow protocol and then I watched the beginning of chips
cause I wanted to see,
uh,
I wanted to see the motorcycles.
You know,
it was a couple Ducati,
so that was cool.
And then the plane landed and then that was fucking it.
That was it.
But I saw two good moves.
I didn't watch enough of chips to know.
You know,
all I wanted to see is where Eric is.
Strada was going to be in it,
right?
It John Baker,
Larry Wilcox,
you know,
they had to be in there.
Right.
I bet the sarge was there.
Baby Grossman.
What about Berry?
You know,
you know what they should've done?
They should've put fucking,
uh,
what's her face in there?
Uh,
Caitlin Jenner.
Bruce Jenner did a couple of seasons on that fucking thing.
Bad.
Fuck,
I made it 30 minutes.
There you go.
That's your podcast for this week.
I apologize.
I know this one stunk.
I just,
I suck when I'm on.
I'm on a plane.
You know what I mean?
I just,
I don't know what the fuck it is.
uh,
it just never seems to work out for me.
Uh,
several Bardo breathing that dirty air and not being able to recline my seat.
I have no idea.
All right.
That's it.
That's the podcast.
Thank you everybody for,
uh,
for listening.
Enjoy the music.
And now we're going to play some,
uh,
classic Thursday afternoon podcasts just before Friday.
Whatever the fuck I call this thing.
Um,
and joy,
the greatest sets.
All right.
That's it.
Have a great weekend.
You can't,
and uh,
I'll talk to you later.
Do you ever get nostalgic for the 90s?
If so,
what part of the night can you have your podcast guy used?
The friends theme song for the Thursday podcast?
That's a question mark or anything awesome from the 90s.
Uh,
because
I don't know,
I have the,
after the cock blocks all been defined,
like the different kind of cock blocks.
I don't know if there's this names thrown,
but I got a new,
I got a new cock block for you.
Uh,
this,
this cock block is very special in a very obvious one.
And I think like this happens all the time,
but for some reason I've never heard anybody name it.
So I'm gonna,
I'm gonna kick off the creative process.
I call this guy the announcer that's,
uh,
that's,
that's the name of this cock block.
This is what happened to me.
Okay.
I was,
I did a Gig in Jersey and at the end of the night,
these two girls who waited to be at the back of the line came up and they said,
hey,
you want to go out and get banana pancakes?
You know,
making a reference to my joke saying if I wanted to go out and hang out with
both of them,
right.
And the second day said it,
I was like,
Holy Shit,
he's a fucking,
here's something I'd never had.
Here's a two on one and I can't fucking do it cause I'm with Nia.
Whose kid?
Nicco not cause I'm with Nias because everyone's got a cell phone,
fucking camera.
And I get caught.
Honesty.
Um,
no,
I couldn't deal with the guilt,
um,
about,
I got it.
I'll be honest with you.
And I would say this,
if Nia was here,
if two fucking tens came up to me and said,
let's do this.
I,
you know,
yeah,
fuck it.
Let's do it.
I never did it,
you know,
fuck it.
So anyways,
so they said,
hey,
you want to get a,
you want to go out and get bananas and pancakes or something like that.
And then this fucking guy like 10 feet array way just goes like,
oh,
you know those guys,
like if a girl just comes up to you,
just like you know,
you know I've always loved guys and green shirts and your thinking raise your
thinking like holy fuck,
this is going to happen.
There's some other guy like five minutes,
hey
and just makes the whole fire the whole fucking room.
Look over at you.
The fucking announcer
fucking cock block mother fucker.
You know who would do that?
If I was standing there and her two girls said to a guy and be like God damn,
it's going down right side of my mouth at lucky motherfucker.
I wouldn't be
okay.
I mean why would you do that?
The fucking announcer.
And if you have a friend like that,
all right,
the only way you can still hang out with them is if he goes out.
If you guys are going out trying to meet women,
he has to wear one of those old ABC bright yellow Monday night football sport
coats.
And if the girls,
why is he wearing that?
You'll see,
you'll see.
And that'll be the,
that would be the funniest fucking thing ever.
Like if somehow if he couldn't figure out the joke and he just thought the coat
look good and just the whole night you just saw him.
Anytime you heard in the,
you know,
10 feet away,
hey just look over and you'd see this guy dressed like Howard Cosell and you'd
be like,
oh that's the announcer.
He's the,
he's the,
he's the guy he can cock block from like he's almost like a sniper.
If he wasn't so fucking loud.
He's at the same distance as a fucking marksman,
but he kills it with a,
with loudness.
Oh my God.
Did that guy fucking annoy me?
Hey Mia,
come here.
Come here.
She just came in shaking her head.
You are what I am beyond the,
come on over here.
I was just telling that story with that Guy Cock block me with those two chicks
out in a Jersey when they would just go cock blocks you.
I told you this story.
No,
but you're making it seem like you were going to do something.
no.
I wasn't going to do something.
This is the thing,
but I just admitted general cock blocking.
Yeah,
but this is what I did admit.
If they will both tens,
I would've,
I would've done it.
I never had a fucking two on one.
And you know something.
Would you be that mad if they were both smoking hot and the cell phone video got
out?
The video is even need to get out when you got the announcer.
Then the guy,
he just literally goes,
yeah,
we'd have to get banana pancakes with Yoda.
He said something.
Okay.
Hmm.
Nothing.
You're a jerk.
Why am I a jerk?
So pajamas
you are talking about cock blocking and two on ones.
What kind of podcasts is this turning into?
You know what,
it's turning into a very honest podcast.
I was very honest.
I said,
this is good for you.
This is the thing I said I couldn't,
uh,
I couldn't deal with the guilt.
Yeah.
Unless if they,
if,
unless they were both Ted's,
if they're both fucking tends to give me a break.
Let me tell you something.
If you hooked up with Brad Pitt,
there's only so mad I could get.
Oh,
it's fucking Brad Pitt.
Okay.
Yeah.
Good to know.
Okay,
well you know what that would if I just,
if I just said some generic,
yeah,
good looking guy.
If I just said some generic good looking guy and you,
and you just said that,
that would have scared me.
But the way you just acted like you had Brad Pitt's phone number.
That doesn't scare me.
Oh really?
Okay.
It's going down.
What if it's the like the regular guy version of Brad Pitt.
Is that okay?
Like he's just as good if you want to go live out on the street and get the fuck
out of this house.
Absolutely.
But you're allowed to have some sort of crazy two.
One one.
Yes.
That's bullshit.
No it isn't.
It is.
If you just,
you know what,
cause you're your thinking on it unlike like a,
a very basic level.
But if you really,
but you really think about it,
just think about it.
It makes sense.
Bill.
You're not going to try to mind fuck me and thinking that it's okay for you to
have some sort of two on one and I can,
that's not,
no,
it's not going down like that.
Yeah,
but God,
women are beautiful.
We,
we lost after you a totally makes sense.
You guys find like Dick's or weird.
They're gross.
It's all hanging out there.
It's disgusting.
You don't want that.
You know nothing about you.
You don't want that which has been proven time and time and again and your stand
up and in your podcasts.
But that's a,
that's another discussion.
You know what you,
you just set yourself up like you're going to make some huge point and then you
just tapped out.
You know nothing about women but,
but the,
but that's just another discussion and I just don't want him to get into that.
So now what?
You just gave me the face.
What are you doing today?
Lazy.
Huh?
What do you mean?
Like is he Nini?
Cool brick?
Yeah.
I just filled my short film over the weekend.
Screw you.
I'm working hard while you're in here in your pajamas talking about two on ones.
Yeah.
Well I have to do an hour's worth a shit here.
I'm coming up on it.
Fill it up with whatever,
an hour and two minutes,
an hour,
two minutes.
If you done your,
uh,
your viewer emails yet?
Yeah,
I did listen their emails.
You did that already because you want to chime in?
I Dunno.
I already did it.
What do you guys already did it?
What about overrated?
Underrated.
Didn't do it.
They didn't have any of this week.
Oh,
okay.
Look at you.
I think you were a fan of this podcast.
No,
I'm not.
Listen,
it didn't go down.
All right,
but I'm telling you right now,
Nia,
if two tens come up to me,
it's going down.
Okay.
All right.
Well,
just be prepared for the retaliation
game set match.
Really?
You're going to deny me that?
Can I just buy you some stuff?
Wow.
Really?
Yes.
Really not some sort of fucking basketball wife that can be placated with
material things to a point.
Yeah,
exactly.
If I'm going to be fucking honest here,
come on.
This gotta be something that I can buy.
You know something.
This should be our Valentine's Day.
All right.
For the guide,
the Guide Valentine's Day,
this is what Valentine's Day should be every year is the guy gets a two on one
and then you get some nice stuff.
Well why can't I have a two on one?
Cause you don't like that.
What do you mean?
What do you know?
Women don't like sex?
You don't find like when you guys fantasize,
you think about the guys in your life.
You don't think about other things.
Um,
come on Nia.
Just one.
Just give me one.
You get one and I get one.
No you don't.
You don't because you don't want one.
What do you mean you just being childish?
No I'm not.
Yeah,
you are.
You,
you say you think you think you want to hook up with,
with Jake Gyllenhaal in a bread face,
whatever the fuck his name is,
Brad Pitt.
Brad thread,
face pit.
You just think you do.
See,
you know what to think about me is,
is like you have to hook up with somebody famous.
I'm actually just regular people.
See I'm down to earth with this shit.
See,
that's what I'm saying.
You like stuff you like shiny,
shiny things.
Oh,
this is the deal.
I get a two on one and you,
you get some some cracked up face old man in Vegas like Robert Redford.
Like I used to be good looking when Nixon was in office.
No,
that's not how negotiating works.
Now you've got to come with something else here.
No,
I think we should both get an equal opportunity thing going on.
Yeah,
but this isn't an equal relationship.
Why?
Why is it not an equal relationship?
Cause I wanted to,
I could pin you down to the ground right now and tickle you until you passed out
and there's not a fucking thing you can do about it.
What did that,
that has nothing to do with anything.
That's how the world works.
Nia,
why do you think America's our top?
Because we're right or because we could,
oh,
because?
Because we can blow you up more times.
Also,
it's your,
your physical presence.
That's what makes it like an unequal relationship.
Yeah.
Cause I can beat you down.
Well,
maybe you're physically stronger,
but I'm mentally stronger than yeah.
Oh
snap.
I'm smarter than you.
Yeah.
So whatever physical power.
Let me ask you this.
What is you have are trumped by my mental fucking Goliath Munis and those suck
on that red.
What do you think?
You're smarter than,
Oh,
that was good though.
You got a good one in and now you're storming off.
I taught you.
Well,
the,
hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and this is the Monday morning podcast.
So Monday,
August 31st,
2009 and I am recording this one from Stockholm,
Sweden.
That's right.
I'm a big shot international traveler.
You know,
not bad for some bomber.
Used to work in a warehouse.
Stockholm,
Sweden,
people.
Um,
I've been here for a week and uh,
it has been absolutely incredible.
I'm not going to lie to you.
It's one of the most beautiful cities I've ever been to and has some of the most
beautiful people I've ever seen.
And I'm not gonna lie to you.
I got to go with a Adolf Hitler on this one.
A,
these are some good looking sons of bitches out here,
you know?
I mean,
I don't think that's an excuse to go out and try to eliminate all the other
races of people.
He took it a little far,
but I can definitely see what he was enamored with.
Like,
I'm not even kidding you like,
like these are some of the most,
even like the guys,
like I was walking down the street with my girl and go look at that fucking guy.
Would you look at them?
Yeah.
How was that guy?
Not Famous?
Sekai would be Brad Pitt and our country.
Look at them.
Even that old people are good looking.
You know what?
All the younger dudes,
they all look like a,
um,
who's that fucking dude with the,
with the Paul Mccartney haircut that all the girls are screaming about.
She's got those Jim Breuer eyes,
you know,
those glassy eyes.
And he's got to fuck.
And a Paul Mccartney Haircut,
I think it was in one of those high school musical,
I dunno,
they all fucking look like that except it's blonde and uh,
and I don't know.
And then,
then the older guys,
they all look like fucking,
uh,
like the bad guy in,
in a Mel Gibson 1980s movie,
you know,
something like that.
And then the women are just absolutely fucking ridiculous.
I saw this girl,
uh,
like,
I haven't even,
you know,
you,
when you walked down the street with your girlfriend,
you try to like subtly look at women.
I was not doing that,
had absolutely no respect for,
I was just going,
Jesus Christ.
And then she,
she wouldn't even punch me if it was in the state.
She would fucking punch me.
But here she was just like,
was,
was that a VJ?
You know,
it was that,
uh,
you know,
they're just fucking gorgeous.
And I'm sitting there and I've never felt like I had a,
that I was compromised genetically until I came to Stockholm,
Sweden,
and I was really starting to get a complex.
But yesterday I took the subway or the,
the on the ground as they call it.
Do you want to find the on the ground?
Uh,
they don't talk like that,
but that's my hacky foreign accent.
Um,
and I took the subway out of Stockholm,
Sweden,
and I went to some of the,
like,
it was almost like I got on the train and I went up to the Bronx.
So like out to Queens.
And that's evidently where they keep all their ugly people and a,
yeah.
All of a sudden I felt like I was in revere,
you know,
or Medford.
So there's definitely some,
there's definitely some struggling people here.
You know what,
you know what it looks like.
Like all this.
Stockholm looks like Soho in New York where everyone's really trendy,
really fashionably dressed and just fucking ridiculously good looking.
And,
uh,
you know,
like I said,
I've never felt like,
uh,
I've never felt like I should be sleeping under a bridge before,
until I came out here.
But anyways,
so with that,
I had one show this weekend,
um,
on the 29th,
I was working the,
uh,
I dunno,
some fucking theater,
I forget the name of it,
but,
uh,
I was all nervous because everybody over here,
even though they're bilingual,
you know,
they,
they fractions fashion,
fashion when they're walking around,
right?
So the comedians going on in front of me are all up there going out on a
[inaudible].
Right.
And I'm fucking sitting back there going,
I don't think these people are going to get what the fuck I'm talking about.
So fortunately I was smart and I,
uh,
I went up the night before my,
my theater Gig is what I did.
I went up the night before and I kind of got all that,
like nervousness out and I was able to figure out just a couple of things to
switch up.
Like,
I made a reference to kickball.
If you guys saw my tonight show set,
I did where I talk about the bankers striking out playing kickball.
They don't know kickball over here.
So one of the other,
uh,
comedians told me switch it to soccer.
I said okay.
And just little adjustments like that.
So I kind of had an okay set,
um,
Thursday,
but I was really on my fucking heels.
I really felt like a freak.
Um,
but then Friday came along and um,
I dunno,
it was,
the theater wasn't packed.
It was sort of like maybe like half full.
So I have this weird psychological thing where if a room is in full,
I don't feel nervous,
but if it's full,
I feel nervous.
And it has nothing to do with numbers.
If you had a room that only held like 40 people and there was 40 people in
there,
I would feel a pressure to kill.
But if you stuck me in a theater,
that health,
like,
you know,
700 people and there was only 400 people there,
I would feel like I was in this little ass crowd.
So that's basically what happened.
And I went out and I had a great time to steroid,
got a standing ovation in the end.
And I was,
I can't even tell you how fucking relieved I was because,
you know,
it took me 16 hours to get here from La.
So you really don't want to bomb.
And,
um,
one of the goals of coming over here was to fucking destroy so that I can start
build building like a following over here because you know,
like most people,
I've always wanted to come to Europe and see all this stuff over here,
but it be even better if I could come over and make a little bit of money.
So that's Kinda my goal,
you know,
going to start,
getting a following over here and I'll fly over here,
I'll make some kronas here in Sweden and then I'll go fucking blow,
blow it all in Italy are fucking,
uh,
Paris Assam Shit.
Why the fuck not right?
Come over here and drink like Ernest Hemingway.
Act like I'm an actual fucking artist rather than someone who curses every other
a word.
But,
um,
so this is the funny part,
right?
So I killed and everything was great and I felt fantastic.
And then the next night,
you know,
they go,
well,
hey,
you know,
we're having this comedy festival,
there's this big theater show.
It's going to be sold out even more people who came out to your show.
Do you want to do it?
And I said,
yeah,
fuck it.
I'll do it because I'll get in front of more people.
Maybe they'll come to my show.
And uh,
like a fucking
typical comic.
I couldn't just leave.
I couldn't leave on a high note.
I had to go for one more and I went up and a,
I only did okay Saturday night I came out a little too cocky and,
um,
I think I kinda came off like an ass.
I didn't suck,
but it wasn't great.
But,
um,
I know it wasn't great because when I got off one of the people was like,
how did you feel about that?
That's fine as long,
you know,
it could have been better when they don't say great job.
When somebody says,
how did you feel about that?
Um,
I dunno,
I'm probably making a bigger deal out of it then it was,
but uh,
but anyways,
it was a,
it was a big success over here and I really miss my dog and I'm ready to go
back.
I got one more day over here today and um,
I actually went to a museum yesterday and they have this,
this uh,
I can't explain what the fuck it is basically in the 16 hundreds.
It's kind of a funny story.
The,
uh,
the king over here commissioned this big battle ship to be built and it actually
had two gun decks,
I think back in the day.
They only usually had one,
but they built two gun decks.
Literally.
I like fucking,
I counted when I went to look at it like they had like,
like 20 some odd cannons on both sides.
It was absolutely huge.
The carvings and the woodworking in the back of the ship and you know,
like the,
the little windows where you open up,
where you stick to the cannons out.
They had like these,
these,
uh,
lions' heads carved in.
I know.
I guess it was something else to intimidate the enemy.
Like the fucking Canon's weren't enough,
you know?
Yeah.
I thought the 20 canons were bad dude,
but they got a fucking,
they got a fake lion head and it doesn't look happy,
you know?
So anyways,
so they commission have this ship built so they build the fucking thing.
Everybody piles on the God damn thing.
They got the guns out and all this shit.
You know.
[inaudible]
if I can go out there in the bay,
it's like a couple thousand people watch
and fucking sec
and I even got to use it.
It'd be like if you bought a brand new car and something,
you know,
you come home,
do it once it got,
I've got three 51 queen,
we don't fucking do a burnout and he just fucking with like eight miles on the
car.
Right.
You wrap it around a pole and not only do you wrap it around a pole,
all your friends fucking watch.
And even though they're your friends,
you know,
they're fucking secretly happy because they can't be happy for you because you
have a better car.
Which means you're going to get better pussy.
So it's just in their DNA,
right?
So they fucking take this boat out there and they say a squall came.
I didn't look up to see what a squall was.
Is that some sort of a storm?
Is it a gust of wind?
I know it isn't a rogue wave.
That's one of the worst lines ever in a movie.
Did you guys ever see perfect storm?
A rogue wave evidently is like this mini tidal wave that just comes out of
fucking nowhere in a lot of times it washes people off the boat.
So,
um,
most people,
you know,
they're not out to see like me.
So you have no idea what the fuck it was.
So if you just showed a rogue wave in a movie,
if the seas were kind of calm and all of a sudden this big wave out of fucking
nowhere,
just washed a couple people overboard,
you,
you would have been like me sitting in the movie theater going,
what the fuck was that?
So they literally had to have mark Wahlberg's character's scream out rogue wave
as it comes in.
Do you remember who would yell that out?
You know,
what'd you yell get,
you know,
get down or whatever the fuck you'd use.
Udl.
Fuck Dude.
That's what you'd yell.
You wouldn't yell.
Like if someone pulled a gun on you and,
and started shooting at you,
you,
you'd be screaming,
running down the alley.
You wouldn't be like,
you know,
38 special.
Anyways,
let me fucking,
let me,
let me plow ahead here.
All right,
so they send this ship out.
Everybody's standing on the shore.
Is everybody's all proud?
Oh yeah.
Look at this sizes they bought.
Look at Zions head.
Yeah,
right.
And the fucking thing is some sort of squall hits it then it,
I don't know what happened.
It started to right itself and then another one hit it and it just fucking went
down.
And when you got two decks of guns,
you go down quick,
like 50 people fucking drowned.
It was just a nightmare.
And evidently they had some sort of stones at the bottom of the boat,
but they didn't have enough.
I think that's to make it sort of sit in the water.
You know,
when it really came across,
it Kinda came across like a,
what Chrysler said,
this is Zucchini Samurai was where it said it tipped over like two miles an hour
because of its center of gravity,
which evidently was a total fucking lie.
They just wanted to sell more jeeps.
But I think that that's basically what happened.
They built this big grand fucking boat and uh,
oh yeah,
they had,
they had trials trying to figure it out.
Everybody was blaming each person.
But anyway,
so the,
if motherfuckers sinks to the bottom of the bay and over time people kind of
forgot where the fuck it was.
And um,
it stayed down there for 333 years before they brought it.
Somebody found it,
they brought it back up and it was in pristine fucking condition.
Jesus is a long way to go.
And me and my girl went to the museum and we saw it.
I'm going to tell you,
it's one of the most amazing fucking things I've ever seen,
which is funny because if you tell anybody in Sweden that you're going to go see
it,
they just laugh at you because I guess his kids,
they always get dragged there and they have to do book reports on it and they
fucking hate the thing.
It's the typical thing.
Think about where you live.
Think about what the tourist attractions are.
You never go to the tourist attractions in your own town.
Okay?
There's just something in human beings DNA where you're like,
dude,
I'm not standing in line in my own fucking town.
You know?
It's like when I lived in New York,
I never went to the statue of Liberty or the empire state building and let,
some friend of mine came to town and they want it to go and I hated every second
of it.
You know,
that's basically the deal.
But if you ever go to Stockholm,
Sweden,
I'm telling you,
you have to go.
You've got to go.
You know,
you gotta go check it out if you're into that type of shit.
It was,
it was unbelievable.
I don't read a lot of this stuff either.
I was getting like sleepy when I start reading the plaques.
I just like looking at the shit and the little fucking boots that they have.
People were so small back then,
you know,
I always wondered if I could go back in time,
like the size I am,
if I would be like the toughest guy in town,
you know,
especially if you've mentioned,
if you took like Jujitsu classes and all the latest fucking fighting styles,
what a God damn bad ass you are.
You'd be,
you know,
now wait a minute.
They had like those fucking spiky
balls that were at the end of the chains.
All right.
Do I sound dumb enough to make this an official fucking podcast?
All right,
let's get on with the podcast.
Um,
Oh,
before I do,
I just want to thank everybody who came out to my,
uh,
to my show at,
at rival rival the however the fuck you said.
Um,
I had a great time and it was an absolute thrill to go onto the other side of
the planet and actually have people know who the fuck I was.
I even brought up my dog and somebody in the crowd yelled out,
Cleo.
There was actually people who,
uh,
listen to the podcast,
which was really awesome and fucking scary all at the same time.
I was like,
yeah,
I've got a dog recently and somebody yelled out,
cleo.
I was like,
yeah,
it was really,
uh,
you know,
your papers please.
Yeah.
You know,
there was that and somebody else was like,
what is that to do out here?
What should I be doing out here?
And somebody in the crowd fucking yelled out,
come to my house,
we'll have a party.
I'm not even exaggerating.
That's what it fucking sounded like.
And I wanted to record that guy in my cell phone and have that as my outgoing
message that if you called me and it went directly to my,
my outgoing message,
that's what would come up rather than,
hey,
this is bill.
Uh,
you know,
leave a message.
You can't,
you know,
it was actually,
it would be him just going
come to my house.
They'll have a party.
Ooh.
All right,
let's plow ahead here.
Oh,
somebody actually informed me that last week was the first time,
uh,
in the history of my podcast,
I did an entire podcast without using the word content.
MMM.
I don't know what that says about that person,
but a,
they're definitely into the podcast.
Okay.
Um,
let's move on here.
Getting on with the podcast.
Uh,
this is,
somebody sent me a really good email about last week when I was,
I was going off on how,
um,
somebody had made fun of Ringo Starr and said something to the effect of,
you know,
cause Ringo said that he wasn't going to be signing anymore anything anymore
after like October.
Basically after 50 years of signing autograph,
that guys approaching 70 years of age,
his wrist is going to fall off.
He's probably going to die within the next decade.
Right.
That's still a good run.
He wants to go do some shit.
So,
of course,
all the fans get pissed and someone's like,
you know,
without us,
he wouldn't be famous.
And I was saying that that was really a,
a,
an arrogant.
Did somebody just knock on the fucking wall telling me to shut up on?
He's yelling.
Yeah.
Um,
I'll go fuck yourself.
I'm just doing a podcast.
Um,
anyways,
so I thought that that was just an arrogant statement.
It's like,
like the fans,
like if it wasn't for the fans,
he wouldn't be famous.
It's like you totally discounting demands talent.
He's considered one of the greatest drummers of all time.
He inspired an entire generation to play drums.
Um,
I dunno.
So anyway,
I can't really even explain my point of view because so much so many in my point
of views are just spur spur of the moment,
you know.
So anyways,
the guy writes 'em on your last podcast,
you were talking about how the fans don't make someone who they are the fans.
And this guy says,
the fans don't make someone talented.
You're right about that.
But without the fans,
all the talent in the world doesn't mean Shit.
How many talented performers have faded away because they failed to find an
audience.
How many know talent ha hacks are making a living in entertainment in the
entertainment industry just because they somehow managed to get a bunch of
mindless fucktard's to buy their crap.
Um,
uh,
yeah,
I mean,
you know,
some,
I understand what you say in there and he brings up this,
this great point of how,
uh,
that that show carnival or Carney val,
however,
the,
however the hell you said it was on HBO and he said to this day,
it's probably the second best show they've ever had behind the wire,
but they canceled the show up to two seasons claiming that the DVD sales weren't
sufficient to justify the amount of money they were spending on making the show.
Um,
yet still shit like 24 which is retelling the same fucking story every goddamn
years in its eighth season.
Just being talented isn't what keeps entertainers employed.
The fans do.
Okay.
Now that's actually,
that's kind of a different argument.
Okay.
I was saying that fans are not the reason Ringo Starr is famous.
If you wanted to say like if it wasn't for the songwriting ability of Paul
Mccartney and John Lennon,
Ringo Starr might've ended up washing dishes.
I would go with that.
I would definitely go with that.
All right.
And I can definitely see that aspect of it.
But to sit there and,
and like put it this way,
if it wasn't for ACDC,
I wouldn't have had a life in my teenage years.
Okay.
And at no or no level do I feel like Angus and Malcolm should thank me for back
in black for the success of back in black.
They made a fucking killer album,
you know,
and they worked their asses off on it and it was so fucking good.
My ears couldn't ignore it.
All right.
I'm not part,
I wasn't part of this group of people who sat there and said,
you know what we're gonna do today?
We're going to make ACDC famous and God damn it,
those sons of bitches better appreciate us because if it isn't,
well,
if it wasn't for us,
the back in black album would suck.
I guess if we didn't buy it,
it w would,
it disappeared into obscurity.
But like I just give ACDC more credit because they're an organized
group of people creating something and I'm just a fucking jackass walking
around.
I don't know.
I don't look at it that way,
but I definitely see,
yeah,
if people don't listen to your shit,
um,
then you don't sell any of it then,
then yeah,
your career is over.
Absolutely.
But I don't feel that buying the shit is in the control of the fans.
I think the artists make something so great.
You have to buy it,
you know?
And as far as like a TV show,
I hate this expression because I don't hunt,
but I'm going to use it anyways.
As far as the TV show goes,
that's an entirely different animal,
man.
I hate when people say that,
but it kind of fits here.
A TV show is different because what you're doing there is you're,
you're trying to go like you're commercially fishing.
You don't give a fuck you,
you're trying to grab as many people as you can
as opposed to just doing what you do.
I can't explain it.
Having a TV show goes beyond doing what you do and if they like,
you know,
build it,
they will come.
It goes beyond that
because you know,
just because they weren't selling enough DVDs,
that's,
is that really a fan thing or is that the [inaudible] in the industry who have
this,
this corporate mentality where every quarter they have to make more money.
You know what I mean?
So it causes them to do things after only two seasons.
I mean,
I don't know.
I'm not trying to belittle people who are fans.
I don't think that artists should take their fans for granted,
but I don't,
I don't feel as a fan of all the people I'm a fan of.
I don't feel like they owe their success to make.
And if they don't want to sign something,
I'm fine with that.
Does that make me fucking weird?
I don't think Ringo Star's 70 fucking years old.
What?
What the what?
What more is he going to?
How many more pairs of Ted's connect I sign.
All right.
It's probably got diarrhea every other Thursday.
I mean,
can the guy fucking live his life?
I Dunno.
All right.
Let's,
uh,
let's,
let's move on here.
All right.
You know what I mean?
Like,
I just went to Stockholm,
Sweden.
I just said,
thanks Dan.
For all the fans who came out,
I don't take them for granted.
You know,
when I was fucking kissing babies and shaking hands at the end of my show,
but I got to admit,
if I'm coming over here,
it's 70.
I want to be wheeled back to my hotel and drink some tea.
And that wouldn't mean that I'm taking them for granted.
It just means I'm fucking old and I'm tired.
Do you know how many autographs Rinko is?
Probably,
you know,
I've already been through this.
He gets no credit.
50 years of autographs.
It's not enough.
And then people are going to take credit for his success.
I just thought that that was a little lot of life.
All right.
That's all I'm fucking trying to say there.
You know?
And like I said,
having said that,
I will be kissing babies and sell it,
signing DVDs and taking pictures with awful fucking digital cameras that for
some reason take like you just don't shoot.
You know,
you got to hold the button down for like 19 minutes and,
and you to,
is it the 18th flash or the 19th flash where I can finally stop smiling.
Um,
alright.
Plowing ahead.
Uh,
Bill.
so something kind of ridiculous happened to me the other day and you're the only
person who I think might appreciate my point of view on the matter.
Okay.
So this is really good looking lady,
uh,
that works at the sandwich shop around the corner from my job.
So I've been going there for like a year now and I've always wanted to say
something to her,
but it never did because either the place was too busy at the time or I just
pushed it out,
usually the latter.
So the other day I finally man up and decide to say something and it went a
little something like this.
Uh,
I go in after two,
so it's not as busy.
I placed my order,
she makes me a wrap.
She hands me a wrap and I say,
excuse me.
Uh,
I've been coming in here for a while and I've always wanted to introduce myself
and before I can even get the words out,
her smiling expression turns blank.
Her lips seal tight and she kind of looks up at her eyebrows with that.
You gotta be fucking kidding me.
Look all over face.
I can only equate a shit.
I just hit the wrong button on my computer.
Um,
he goes,
I can only equate the look to an a to an employee,
what an employee you might have when they're done with their work for the week
and on Friday evening,
right as they feel like they're going to get out of there,
the boss comes and drops another hour's worth of paperwork on their desk.
They can't say anything,
but you know the thinking,
you fucking prick.
So what I ended up saying after I get this look from this chick is this is
basically what the guy says.
He said,
excuse me,
I've been coming in here for a while and I've always wanted to introduce myself.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Never mind.
Okay.
And he goes,
I turned around and I just walked out.
All right?
And he goes,
now,
here's my issue,
dude.
We've all been there.
All right,
we've all fucking been there.
Um,
all right.
So he goes,
now here's my issue.
It's not that I was rejected.
Big Deal.
That shit happens all the time,
right?
Uh,
that's like an ongoing theme in an adult life and I've learned to live with it.
Jesus,
dude,
don't jump off a cliff here.
Um,
he goes,
my problem is that sets,
this says as a society,
I can't even talk to a society that,
but my problem is society dictates that the guy should approach the girl and all
the girls really needs to do is look pretty,
throw a few signals and wait for dudes to start clamoring like morons.
Is it fair?
No.
But then again,
it's really not a big deal.
It's one of the situations you grow accustomed to.
But if that is the case and if all women have to do is be pretty,
then say yes or go fuck yourself.
Could they at least wait 30 seconds for me to say whatever retarded shit,
whatever retarded shit I'm thinking before they shoot me down.
All she has to do is wait a minute and say,
no thank you.
But instead I get cut off by Stinkeye mid sentence.
Should I have told her to go fuck herself?
What are your thoughts on this sort of shit?
Your true and loyal fan?
Bobo.
The douchebag.
Alright.
Um,
what am I failings on this?
All right.
First of all,
dude,
we've all been there.
We've all,
you know,
you got in your head,
you're going to come up there like fucking Sean Connery and one of those early
James Bond's even feel like you got to fucking Tuxedo on.
And then the second you open your mouth,
you sound like fucking Arnold Horshack and you even want to shoot yourself down
at that point.
Okay?
Um,
but to answer your question,
should I have told her to go fuck herself?
No,
that's not.
I mean I'm,
I'm just,
you know,
having not been there,
I,
I can't,
it'd be,
it would depend on what the look on her face was or how she looked.
You know,
if,
uh,
if she was just some hot girl who didn't have a brain in our head,
yeah.
Then you tell her to go fuck herself.
But this is a really cute girl and you actually feel like,
wow,
I,
you know,
I'd like to get to know that girl.
No,
you don't tell her to go fuck herself.
It's actually in that moment when she gives you the stink eye is when you have
to come up with something funny to say something,
something clever,
something.
See you show that you're not going to quit in life.
Cause that's what I hate to say dude.
But that's what you showed her.
You showed her that you have,
you have the quit DNA in your fucking ball bag and she's not going to want to
meet with you.
But fortunately there's plenty other gazelles out there on the fucking Serengeti
that you can try to run down.
You see the discovery channel.
Cheetah doesn't always fucking run the thing down.
Sometimes it gets kicked in the face and then it sits there feeling stupid,
especially when it realizes that it's being filmed.
It's going to be on basic cable.
There's where you can,
you can actually look at a bright side.
It wasn't filmed did you?
You just got to kind of come up with something in that moment.
That's funny.
And I actually kind of thought about it,
what I would have said and I would have choked even if I tried to come up with
something funny because in the moment I would have felt like a Douche and I
probably would have attacked what she did for a living,
which is the worst thing you can do.
We like really,
you know,
you fucking,
you've been working here for a year and a half,
two years I've been seeing making sandwiches.
You're not getting any younger this sweetie.
All right.
You know,
I would,
it would have been bad.
It would have been bad.
It's very easy for me,
you know,
for me to sit here and tell you what you should've done.
You know,
it's kind of like,
uh,
you know,
when you,
when you watch a football game or something like that and once it ends and
whatever the game plan was,
didn't work out.
They do.
What did they give it to Marshall?
Foch I don't understand.
Um,
it's easy to do that.
So,
um,
I don't know what to tell you.
Like,
you know,
be funny.
You got to go back there and keep ordering sandwiches.
I don't know.
That's fucking humiliating.
You might,
you might have to find a new place to get a sandwich.
Dude.
I gotta be honest with you.
I don't know how you pull yourself out of that one.
What did you say?
You know what?
Fuck it.
Oh,
this is what you do.
Jake Heights is just in and just kind of be a dick.
You know,
once you could just walk up,
hey sunshine or something.
I don't listen to me.
All my shit just always ends up with,
you know,
if there's a reason I get heckled as much as I do because I'm an asshole.
Um,
but as far as like a,
what you said earlier,
cause I know there's a lot of women pulling their fucking hair out right now
when you say all the woman has to do is be pretty and wait for the offers to
come in.
Um,
I dunno dude,
if you ever had a girlfriend,
first of all,
that whole thing of looking pretty from my standpoint and my experience takes at
least four and a half fucking hours.
And um,
and you never know.
That girl might might've been giving you the stink eye because she's a really
good looking girl and she,
she has a public,
she has a job where she deals with the public.
So believe it or not,
the amount of ugly fucking Addis shape dudes who actually don't have a problem
approaching beautiful women,
uh,
is actually,
it's the,
it's pretty high.
I mean,
personally I think it's funny,
but,
um,
if you're a woman,
it's not as funny.
And I think that's something that took me a long time to realize how like I'm
uncomfortable.
That feeling can be,
you know,
cause guys,
snake,
dude,
I would love to be standing there and women hitting on me.
But would you have to do is you've got to see how we're physically made up.
The fact that a guy,
you know what,
what if there was this thing that physically could beat the shit out of you and
it wanted to enter your body?
That's the only way to try to put yourself and the,
and what if it's,
if you had not attracted to it and you feel it getting angry when you're trying
to communicate that,
you know you're all set,
you know,
and then there's the option that if they wanted to,
they could give you a forearm shiver and begin to execute their plan.
You know,
oh Jesus,
how do I talk myself out of this one?
You know what it's like,
put it this way for all the guys listening out there,
if somebody said,
hey man,
I'll give you 10 bucks.
This is like an old joke.
I still my act,
I'll give you 10 bucks to walk over to that birth.
Keep birthday cake and stick your finger in it.
Yeah,
got you.
10 Bucks.
Yeah.
Fuck it.
I'll do it.
You know,
20 bucks or whatever.
Just something,
you know,
you do it.
You wouldn't think anything about it.
Whatever.
Stick it in.
You take it right back out.
You know,
you wouldn't give a fuck.
What if somebody said,
dude,
I'll give you,
I'll give you 20 bucks to take that cake and put it in your ass.
See what I mean?
There'd be a difference then.
Then you,
you would have some questions.
You know,
where's that kicked Ben?
Are you going to tell anybody?
I usually don't do things like this.
You know,
that's,
that's why women,
they approach sex that way.
You know,
they got to have rules on when they're going to fuck you and all that.
It's,
it's,
uh,
did that,
that,
that example.
But I know on some level it made sense.
I'm a little jet lagged.
I done that joke in a while and I got halfway through and it didn't even make
sense to me.
I'm just saying it,
you know,
did I answer your question?
Um,
so this is what you gotta do.
You gotta treat a,
you've got to treat women like,
uh,
like I treated open mikes.
Okay.
You just know you're going to bomb and eventually you're going to get good at
it.
So just keep,
you know,
make some notes what you're going to do the next time that happens.
You know,
maybe try to come up with a couple of lines and I hope women,
I hope you appreciate,
uh,
what a fucking pain in the acid is for a guy to get laid.
You know what I mean?
And that's why there's the whole,
um,
stud whore double standard.
Because basically for a guy to get laid,
this is what he has to go through.
This guy actually has to develop skills to get laid.
You know,
all you have to do is show up,
you know,
I mean,
for a guy,
the brass ring is getting a two on one.
No TV credits.
No,
my dad has a yacht.
You just get it from talking shit.
That is the brass ring for a guy.
Now a woman,
her first night of fucking all she'd have to do is laid out in a pool table.
She could fuck every guy in the bar.
It's not a skill.
It's gluttonous.
You know,
Scott Ness,
it's like watching a fat guy eat an ice cream.
You never catch up,
you know,
kind of many slack.
Haven't you had enough?
Um,
all right,
I'm really glad I read it,
this podcast because this other one was not nearly as fucked up as this one.
I don't know if it's funny,
but it's definitely fucked up.
Okay,
here we go.
Uh,
there's another one.
Um,
Bill,
I'm getting laid off at the end of the month.
Naturally,
I would like to go to the dentist before my benefits run out.
What a sad fucking state.
You know what I mean?
Jesus Christ.
I really believe that people should have,
you should have some sort of fucking healthcare.
We really need to overthrow these fucking bankers because there's plenty of
money out there.
If those banker comments weren't fucking charge in the u s government interest
for its own fucking money plowing ahead.
Um,
anyways,
here we go.
Uh,
since I did not care much for my current dentist,
I asked my fiance for the name of hers.
All right,
so just get you caught up if you didn't get lost at my moronic rant with no
information behind it there.
Okay.
This guy's getting laid off.
He wants to get his teeth cleaned before it's health insurance runs out.
He doesn't like his dentist.
So he asks his fiance for the name of hers.
He says my,
uh,
my fiance is Vietnamese and gave me the name of her dentist who was also
Vietnamese.
Bear in mind,
this is a typical Vietnamese dentist's office.
You have a dentist and office manager who is usually a woman over 50 and two or
three.
And he writes this in capital letters,
hot Asian hygienists.
I had a cleaning firm,
one of the hygienists who couldn't have been more than 20 years old and screamed
of junior college.
This was the high point of her career until she landed that Mrs degree,
I don't even know what that is.
Maybe I'm dumb.
I'm so,
anyways,
I'm getting my teeth cleaned.
We were flirting back and forth.
The appointment ended.
And we headed to the old 50 plus office manager before I could even utter a
word,
the old bag of bones said,
and broken,
broken English.
This appointment is covered,
but you can't come back until you find another job.
Jesus Christ.
Anyways,
he says,
my hot hygienists,
who up until that time was totally into me,
quickly looked at the floor and made an immediate beeline to the nearest
unoccupied exam room.
Now I am not a racist,
but I was so mad.
There's a sentence like this never ends good.
Okay.
Anything that starts with,
I'm not racist,
k but these motherfucking,
anyways,
um,
he says,
now I am not a racist,
but I was so mad that I could've slapped that bitch back to the Vietnamese rice
patties of 1974.
Here we go.
He's not racist.
Everybody.
How could she say that?
Especially in front of the Hottie who was obviously as dumb as she looked,
Jesus Christ.
Dude.
Uh,
when I got back to work,
I told my coworkers the story and they implied that I was the victim of reverse
racism.
If I was Asian and had eyes that couldn't see through a key hole,
Jesus Christ,
dude,
she would,
she would have bitter tongue or said something more appropriate.
What do you think?
Uh,
okay.
What do I think?
All right.
Let me go with my first thought.
A thought number one,
dude,
you should not be getting married.
You should not be getting married.
Okay.
Especially because not only are you hitting on these fucking women,
you're so fucking
like end of this shit.
Like you just told me you were engaged and now you're dragging me into your
bullshit.
And I'll tell you when people do that,
like I don't mind if a guy cheats on his girl.
I don't give a fuck.
Just don't drag me into it,
you know?
So then I got to fucking fix my face to the next time I see your girlfriend.
Don't you hate when people do that?
You know,
do what you do,
what you do.
Do what you do.
Do it over there.
Don't do it near me.
See what you,
now you're telling me you're,
you're fucking engaged and now you're,
you're hitting on,
first of all,
why are you hitting on this girl?
You know why?
I'll tell you why.
Because you're not done fucking and because you're not done fucking,
you're setting yourself up,
dude,
for a brutal,
brutal situation.
The last thing you should be doing is getting married.
You shouldn't even have a fucking girlfriend right now.
Okay?
And then there's a whole weird thing where your girlfriend's Vietnamese,
you go in here and they got all these hot Vietnamese girls and you're saying
he's not racist,
but then you're saying fucked up shit about them.
But I will give you the benefit of the doubt,
doubt,
benefit of the doubt.
Because this is written.
Okay?
And the one thing that sucks about writing shit is you lose the tone.
And a lot of times people are trying to joke around.
So it might've been the way I read it.
So we'll leave all of that out of there.
But Dude,
I'm gonna tell you right now,
you,
you should,
the biggest fucking thing about this is don't get married.
You're not ready to get married.
Okay.
I think you're ready to go to Vietnam and fucking hit a single's bar.
I think you're ready to do that,
but you are not ready to be married,
so don't fucking do it.
All right.
You know,
just sit down and ask yourself,
am I done?
Fucking,
I guess other women because that's what you sign up for and um,
you're going to lose half your shit and you're going to have to,
even if you don't have a kid,
you're going to have to pay alimony.
At least that's how it works in New York where you have to pay.
How about if you're married seven years for three and a half years,
you have to pay alimony to a healthy human being who really should just go out
and get a fucking job,
but for some reason they don't have to.
So,
um,
that's my advice.
I would say don't get married,
but as far as,
were you an example of reverse racism now?
You were,
uh,
you were a victim of a 50 year old woman who is the typical front desk person at
any medical place.
They always yell out intimate information,
like information,
you know,
constantly because they're so in the job that they stop understanding that
they're in front of the public.
That shit.
Hey,
you know,
you walk in there,
oh,
you know,
Mr. Johnson,
did you get that appointment?
How did it work out?
They'll yell that across the,
you know,
I actually worked in a dental office and I saw people get haggling over money
all the time at the fucking front desk and a,
I saw it bother a lot of people.
And um,
I don't know.
Um,
I don't think you were a victim of reverse racism.
I think that the,
uh,
old bag of bones as you call her a pro probably would have said that to anybody
else.
She sounds like,
you know,
you kind of have to be a tough person to work the front desk because a lot of
people try to get out of pay in their shit.
So,
um,
your,
what you should've done was talk to the dentist or even taken her aside.
And that's what you do in that situation.
Just be like,
look,
you know,
I understand that.
I don't have a job right now and you really don't need to be yelling that.
I think you owe me an apology.
That's the way you handle it.
You know what I mean?
I wouldn't go the reverse race.
You've got to understand this concept every race.
So don't take it racially.
You know,
if she said,
hey,
round die.
Once you go get a job at Dunkin donuts so you can afford the next fucking
payment.
All right?
You Fat.
Fuck.
You know she said something like that.
Yeah,
but she kind of laid the facts that she was rude,
she was rude.
Uh,
that's what I would go with on that one.
But then again,
I wasn't there.
All right.
What am I up to here?
Dirty nine.
Okay.
I gotta read this revenge story.
Then I got to get off my day,
cause this is my last day in Stockholm,
Snead and Yang,
and I want to go have a good time.
All right.
Um,
I called this part revenge of the revenge stories.
All right,
here's a revenge story that comes back.
I'm bringing this,
this topic back.
Here's this guy's revenge story.
Um,
you always hear about people fucking up someone's car.
I actually used this guy's car to fuck him up and no,
I didn't run him over or any stupid shit like that,
like that.
This was more and much more fun.
I was employed by a company that made electronic equipment for computers a
number of years back and I drove one of my,
uh,
I drove one of the many forklifts in the warehouse during the regular day shift.
It was one of those warehouses,
um,
where the warehouse,
the administration was an all in one building,
which meant that everyone employed in the company worked in the same location.
I'm the warehouse manager at the time.
My boss's boss was this short Mexican dude who stood about five foot five and
was a fantastic shitbag asshole.
Oh,
I'm just going to let you digest that and never heard that vulgarity put
together that way.
Fantastic.
Shitbag asshole to anyone taller than him,
which meant pretty much the entire planet with the exception of China and maybe
one island in Indonesia.
Indonesia got on bed.
Um,
he believed that leadership meant he could be an asshole to him or whoever,
whoever damn well he pleased and it pleased him a whole fucking lot to be an
asshole to me.
I won't bore you with the issue with or your listeners with the details,
but as Napoleon complex drove his actions more than any other reason,
this is what always happens when I start to read them bad.
I think if I read it faster,
I will,
uh,
start reading it better.
Why don't I take a breath,
slow down and read the rest?
Okay,
here we go.
Here comes the revenge.
Uh,
my job would be on the line if I outrage outright fuck outright faced off with
this guy.
So abroad would be out of the question.
And frankly,
the whole morale of the workplace with Lyft a little bit.
If this shit bag was taken down a notch or two.
So I decided to take matters in my own hands without the use of physical
violence or property damage.
Now this here is actually a unique way to go.
All right,
here we go.
He said,
uh,
what I did was,
is I,
I put up the A,
I put up his car for sale and here's how I did it.
At the time I worked for this company,
the PT Cruiser had just come out and this Mexican closet case went out and
bought himself one.
Maybe he thought they weren't as gay as everyone else knew they were,
but hey,
this fuck nut didn't have both oars in the water in the first place.
Um,
some months before I struck up a great friendship with this chick who worked at
the front desk who also doubled as a human resource assistant.
I took her out to lunch as in a,
at a place of her choosing an exchange for this shitbags home phone number.
Here's where the fun begins.
I picked up two different local newspapers and I took out ads for the,
in the classifieds for this guy's car and arrange to have the,
have them run for a week.
The ads basically said that I had a brand new PT cruiser for sale for less than
half the cost of the new one and I had to leave the country soon but couldn't
take the car with me.
I also worked at odd hours and the best time to get ahold of me would be between
the hours of one and five in the morning.
Newspapers got really lax about their classified ads used to be,
they'd call the number you gave them to make sure it wasn't bullshit.
But since the Internet and craigslist took over,
they rarely checked.
I placed the same ad and two papers on Monday afternoon and quietly waited.
Wednesday rolls around and I can already see the result of my handiwork.
This fucker shows up to work without a shave.
Pores themselves fuck loads of coffee all day while cowering in his office.
Like one of those baby monkeys with the wire cage mother.
I don't know what that means.
Um,
he'd obviously been getting calls at fuck all hours of the night and couldn't
sleep for shit.
It may have cost me a couple of bucks to get the ads up.
But to see this asshole bloodshot and out of his head more,
more than made up for it,
that's actually pretty decent.
Um,
and with that I'm going to do overrated,
underrated.
And I actually have to commend that guy cause there was no physical violence,
didn't chop his hair off.
He didn't fuck up his car.
He just had people,
uh,
he had,
I like all he also like somehow had other people doing his dirty work for him.
Um,
I give that one an eight.
Alright.
[inaudible] overrated,
underrated.
Televised Poker.
Who wants to watch a group of Asians with mullets sit at a table,
sober playing cards.
You know,
you guys are really getting good at this writing shit,
I think,
uh,
with each week when you write these in,
it's making it easier for me to be funny.
Uh,
Nancy Grace,
this media horror needs to change her fucking Tampon or get a good night's Dick
in her.
All right.
Child beauty pageants.
Mom never want any beauty contests.
So it's real important for her to her fucking that are fucking spawn does.
All right.
You know what,
I'm done reading.
I don't know what happened.
I can't read anymore.
These are all great.
I should read the rest of them next week.
I'm too fucking tired.
I've been stuttering over everything.
Um,
let's just end this God damn podcast abruptly.
MMM.
I want to thank the person who sent me the a ram super bowl and um,
I actually went on the Internet and watched a number of other super bowls and
I'm not going to tell you where they are for fear that the NFL is going to take
them down.
But they had the,
mmm.
The original broadcast,
not the NFL film version.
They had the original broadcast of a Superbowl three and all four of the
Superbowls that the Steelers won in the 70s.
And I got to tell you,
it's a real football education to watch those games without like,
I mean,
I love NFL films style beautiful.
They make it in the drama and the music and everything.
But to watch the,
you know,
some of them even had the commercials.
They will fucking incredible.
If you want to know where they're at,
just email me and I'll,
I'll let you know where they're at.
But um,
which is stupid cause if someone from the NFL is listening to this,
they send me an email,
whatever you can find them.
But anyways,
like I just,
I watched super bowl three and um,
you know,
Joe Namath was,
I,
it really reminded me of Dan Marino.
Like he couldn't sack the guy.
He's totally picking up the blitz.
He had that quick release.
He was,
he was really picking them apart and uh,
but I
[inaudible] the cults just fuck themselves.
They threw three interceptions
in their own end zone,
not their own end zone.
And the jets end zone.
Like they,
they literally like conservatively left like 23 points on the table in the
first.
Um,
and the first half alone,
and I'm not taking anything away from the jets here because they played a
phenomenal game,
but like,
uh,
that Earl moral man,
he just,
he was the MVP of the NFL that yeah,
year took over for Johnny Unitas,
I guess the guy's elbow was,
uh,
was all tore up so he couldn't play.
But I mean he had one,
he had a touchdown.
It,
it's like a three yard pass and he threw it like Brett farm.
He threw it like 90 miles an hour to the guys outside shoulder at the flecks off
them.
Easy touchdown.
And it'll shoots up in the air.
It gets picked off.
They had a flea flicker at the end of the half and this Guy Jimmy or is wide
open jumping up and down.
He misses him and he throws into to fucking,
I mean tactically it wasn't double coverage,
but there was jets all around the guy.
They throw another fucking pick.
I watched three
watch Superbowl nine,
which is a great game.
The first half total defensive struggle.
And then in the third quarter of Franco Harris starts running wild.
And it really wears down the front four of a,
the Steelers and the Steelers defense.
It's just fucking incredible.
And I'm something I didn't know Terry Bradshaw was fast.
See,
I was too young to,
to know that I saw older Terry when he couldn't run anymore.
He ran a four five 40 and he was at definite threat.
But um,
and then
Bolton killed me because I was a huge cowboy fans in the,
in the 70s and watching them
kind of,
you know,
they went up 10 to nothing in the first half and just they were playing real
loose and then they went like halfway through the second quarter they started
playing Marty Ball.
They just,
it was sitting on the this 10 nothing lead with two and a half quarters to go.
I fucking could not understand it.
And then all of a sudden the Steelers just creep back into the game.
And next thing you know they're down by like,
I dunno,
six points.
Then they open it up again and they fucking score touchdowns.
I'd,
I was really frustrating as a cowboys fan,
but I got to tell you,
watching those great Steelers teams was incredible and super bowl 10.
Lynn Swann has,
I believe,
the greatest performance of any wide receiver in Superbowl history.
And that includes Jerry Rice.
He,
he,
he has arguably two of the greatest catches in NFL history.
Forget about the super bowl.
The guy had like four catches for like 160 yards and that last pass that Terry
Bradshaw's throws him is one of the best pastors have ever seen in my life.
I'm telling you,
go on,
go on the Internet,
find them.
There's a of shit up there.
This,
that game where a Joe Montana becomes a superstar,
that game where he fucking throws it to Dwight Clark.
If you're an uh,
you know,
if you're a younger guy and you never got to see those games of telling,
you just go on the Internet,
you know where the fuck to go and find them because they're,
uh,
they're absolutely incredible.
And,
um,
I dunno,
I got to watch three Superbowls I'd never seen before.
I had basically plus the rams.
So I watched four super bowls.
That's what I did in Stockholm,
Sweden when I couldn't sleep.
Um,
I know I'm babbling right now and this is only interesting to a football fans.
God Damn,
I forgot to talk about that keg rater again.
I saw this story on the Internet.
I saw this TV show with this guy.
He got a Kegerator,
which I had never heard of before.
It's basically looks like a big desk,
you know,
some of the bigger ones,
but it basically,
it holds a keg in there and you just have beer on tap.
Any wield it.
He had an in his kitchen and of course his wife is like,
honey,
it's ugly.
It doesn't match anything.
And what is this fucking sad sack do?
Does he say it's my kitchen too?
Eh?
They give a shit back?
No.
He's like,
Ooh.
And she,
you know what?
They fucking wield the thing out into the garage.
Okay.
And he's like,
well,
how'd the garage,
and I'll turn this into a man cave.
Why?
You know something?
If you're a man and you've been banished to your basement or your fucking
garage,
what the fuck is wrong with you?
You know what I mean?
I just,
I don't understand that.
Why
it's just not a partnership.
I couldn't believe it.
But you know what?
It did really make me do as I want to get a fucking CAGR rater.
You want a reason why I'm not going to,
cause if I had one,
not only wanted it to be a fucking raging alcoholic,
I would weigh a good two 40 I could have blocked for Franco Harris and fucking
Superbowl nine if I had a Goddamn Kegger rater.
But I'm telling you,
you know,
if you're one of those people who doesn't give a fuck and you're already an
alcoholic,
if you want to cut down in some of the expenses of,
you know,
we're always having to go to a store and then everyone's trying to have an
intervention and try to help you not be an alcoholic so they won't go to the
store anymore and you don't have to be standing there going,
get me the booze.
Like that dude on intervention.
Get a fucking kegger.
[inaudible]
it's,
I'm telling you,
I didn't even know that they existed.
I just wish I was like,
you know,
15,
20 years younger and those things existed.
Or maybe they did.
I never heard of him,
but I would have had one in my apartment back in my old bachelor of fucking
days.
And how would it had shit on tap because that's back then you remember back then
your 20s was the tail end and we could fucking eat,
drink 12 beers and eat McDonald's and somehow wake up with a flat stomach and
barely a headache.
I swear to God,
I've never done a,
I did a commercial early on in my career long fucking time ago,
my career.
Um,
but don't,
I kind of got away from it after a while.
I don't know why,
but uh,
that's something I would have no problem doing a fucking commercial for.
You know,
I would have no fucking problem whatsoever doing a commercial for a,
uh,
for a Kegger Raider,
you know,
cause that's something I would fucking use.
Oh,
by the way,
somebody sent me this hilarious fucking email.
This is going to be when these classic podcasts where I,
Sam wrapping it up and then I do another 15 minutes.
Where the fuck is it?
This guy sent me this hilarious email.
Remember last week when you guys asked me about,
somebody asked me about the bloggers.
Okay.
And,
uh,
I,
you know that,
that supermodel who outed the blogger and I basically said,
uh,
that I could see,
you know,
I could see both sides of it.
Why the fuck is it?
Somebody was really pissed at me for a God damn it,
where is it on any level.
Okay.
Supporting that supermodel.
I can basically paraphrase what they said,
but what they wrote was so fucking funny though.
Ah,
God damn it.
I can't find it.
They basically said,
uh,
sticking up for celebrities.
I knew you moving to La was a bad move.
Uh,
and it was something else about me being a sellout and then it just said,
fuck you,
bye.
You know,
and I,
I just wrote back,
I was just like,
okay,
have a good one.
I just thought it was funny.
You know,
I just think it's funny when people complain.
Uh,
I dunno.
There's like,
people have that thing.
If you move to la,
like you become a phony.
It's like all that road really proves his was I was already a phony and that
you,
you don't become a phony moving out to la.
You,
you're,
you're either a phony or you're not this phony people on the fucking east coast.
How many times do you fucking cunts back on the east coast got to get fucked
over by somebody in business or like,
dude,
yeah,
I'll be there.
Yeah,
I'm going to pay you back.
How many fucking times when people got to do shit like that before you realize
that there's this console over the country.
All right.
This constant la too.
It's just better whether that's,
see that's the only difference.
All right.
That's it.
That's the end of the podcast.
Thank you guys for listening and thanks to everybody in Sweden who came out to
the rival,
a theater where I was at.
And uh,
thanks to everybody for keeping this podcast alive with your questions and all
that type of stuff.
I hope all you guys have a good week and I will talk to you next Monday.
Yeah.
All right.
Lock the next week.
[inaudible].